but evening well I said am excited about
what now what about being here now
listen you you read the nominations and
I'll announce the winner
okay the nominees for best achievement
in live-action short films are graffiti
Diana Costello producing Molly's pilgrim
Jeff Brown and Chris Peltzer produces
rainbow war Bob Rogers producer and the
winner is
Molly's pilgrim Jeff Brown and Krista
producers
they don't have to thank their mother
they brought her with them dad - this is
really amazing I want to thank the
Academy and I want to thank Barbara
Cohen who wrote the book that we adopted
adopted adapted and Sophia Aaliyah's OVA
for being Molly she was the lead in the
film and a Russian immigrant herself and
this is really a wonderful way to be
welcome to Hollywood
thank you I'd like to give a special
thanks to the Board of Governors for
allowing me to be here
of course sir we really don't deserve to
be here it's only because they couldn't
put all the crew members names and the
cast members names on here this is for
them thank you and as the executive
producer we dedicate this film to all
the immigrants to all the aliens and to
all the pilgrims seeking safe haven
thank you
ladies and gentlemen Jim McGeorge is
Stan Laurel and Chuck McCann as Oliver
Hardy